Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sambha Sambhodassam Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sambha Sambhodassam
Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sambha Sambhodasa Homage to the Buddha, the blessed, noble and fully self-awakened one.
So last talk, we did the whole business of how the mind experiences the body.
And we looked especially at those four great elements and stuff, yeah?
so but of course there is the body as a as an organism and uh i just the first thing that always strikes me about this little book called human body and whenever i pick it up and read a bit i'm absolutely gobsmacked so for instance the brain contains 12 billion neurons and 50 billion supportal glial cells
That's 12 billion neurons.
The mind boggles.
You can fit all that inside your skull.
12 billion.
It's an amazing figure.
And then it goes on about the spinal cord.
So there's another one here.
This is even slightly more interesting in a way.
Every second, 2 million oxygen-bearing neurons
red blood cells die.
Every second, two million oxygen-bearing red blood cells die.
I mean, it's just, I don't, I'm not aware of that, are you?
but they are replaced at the same rate by new ones generated in the process of erythropoiesis, something like that anyway.
And this begins in the kidney cells, which are stimulated by low oxygen levels to release a hormone.
I'm not going to say that again.
The hormone travels to the body's red bone marrow, which stimulates increased production, raising
the blood oxygen levels.
And these cells have to make their way through the bone into the blood.
Well, that's remarkable, isn't it?
So when you read books like this and you realise all this stuff's going on and you haven't a clue, absolutely haven't a clue, you do feel a bit like sort of a body snatcher, like you're in this body and that somehow you're not really connected.
So that's our first contemplation, really, that the mind simply doesn't know this stuff.
There's nothing in the Buddha's teaching.
I mean, if he'd have known, for instance, that malaria was carried by mosquitoes, I think he'd have told us.
But he didn't.
And it's, you know, like, you probably know that the word malaria comes from the Italian malaria, bad air, because the Romans thought it was the bad air off the swamp that was giving them the illness.
So it's only in very recent times over the past 100 or so, 50 years, that we've got these sort of facts.
And what comes across to me is that every one of these little cells produces its own energy and a bit more for us.
And it's got its own little intelligence.
It knows what it's supposed to do.
It's supposed to go and pick up oxygen, deposit and then die.
And it's just remarkable, right?
So it's sort of contemplating the fact that
We have this connection with the body, which is absolutely intimate.
Our identity lies with the body.
How do you know that?
You know that when serious illness comes along, when death looms you in the face, the fear, the anxiety that comes, even though everybody, you know, all this science is telling you, you can't be the body.
The body is made up of billions and billions of cells and they're all dying.
They're all dying all the time.
the cornea in your eye is changed every week.
Every week, got a new cornea, got a new eye.
Amazing.
And supposedly, the body changes all its cells within a period of seven years.
So, I mean, I've had ten bodies.
Ten completely renovated bodies.
It's amazing.
No, seven.
Ten.
No, ten.
Actually, I've got my maths right.
Ten completely re-geared bodies.
I shall leave you with that.
So now the Buddha knows this, of course.
He knows that the body is not him or whatever.
And there's a whole discourse which is devoted to the body.
It's called the Kaya Gati Sati Sutta.
So Kaya means body.
Gati means towards the body or going or about the body.
Sati means awareness of it.
And Sutta means discourse.
And I must put you onto this website.
It's absolutely wonderful.
It's run by a monk called Ananda Jyoti, who's an English fellow, who was with me in the monastery I was at in Burma.
And he's ended up being quite a good, a very good scholar.
And he lives now in Thailand.
And what he's done with a various amount of...
of discourses he's put the translation underneath the Pali so you can actually see how the words all connect it's really sort of quite interesting for those of you who want to know a bit of Pali
So anyway, it starts off with the monks being in this hall and they're saying, wonderful friends, marvelous friends, how it is said that the gracious one who knows, who sees, the worthy one, the perfect Sambuddha, mindfulness related to the body when it has been developed and made much of, yields great fruit and brings great advantages.
And then just then, the Buddha's got up from his seat and he's interrupted them.
And he said, what were you talking about before I came in?
So they tell him that they've been talking about this contemplation of the body.
So he takes the opportunity to go into it in greater detail.
And the first thing, of course, he goes into is the breath.
Now, when you read this, it translates as
he breathes...
So he sits cross-legged, setting his body up straight.
He goes to the wilderness, to the root of a tree, to an empty place.
And that normally means...
that in the wilderness is the cold season, the root of a tree is in the hot season, and the hut is in the rainy season.
That's what it's sort of referring to.
So this is the life of those ascetics at the time.
And he sits with his legs cross-legged and all that sort of stuff, establishes his mind in front of him, he breathes in, he breathes out.
And while breathing in a long breath, he knows, I am breathing in a long breath.
Now, the Pali, you see, is Digan Asasami.
The words, the verb in Pali is like Italian.
It includes the pronoun, right?
So, me means I, ti means you, and so on and so forth.
So, you can't really say, it's the same in Italian, you can't say, let me think of a word, amo, ami, ama.
so it's you know you love I love you love and so on and so forth and the way that you get over it in Italian is by using the pronoun so scendere scendere levare scendere right now so you've got to be careful about this I business so in our noting
we just say rising and falling but you can't actually say that in Pali unless you use the infinitive so you have to be a little careful when you read this stuff simply because it seems as though he's noting but it could also just be a reflection and then you observe the breath so remember noting technique is specific to the Mahasi Sayadaw but also I found out was used by
a Zen teacher, Maezumi Roshi, in America.
So it's not completely unknown in other traditions.
Now, the word he uses here is paginati, so that ñ to know comes right through to our language as gn, so it's knowledge, kn, right?
And the pa means to really know, and we translate it as insight, to actually really feel, to realise paginati, to actually experience it, right?
And he uses that for knowing there's a short breath and a long breath and so on and so forth.
And then he says, trains himself.
He uses a different word, sikkati, to train himself, experiencing the whole body.
I will breathe in the whole body.
I will breathe out and making the bodily process calm.
I will breathe in.
Making the bodily process calm, I will breathe out.
So there's your Samatha quality, right?
And that's the beginning of any of our meditation, is to just try to settle the mind on the breath a little bit.
And then when you're settled, you open up, right?
He trains himself.
What he doesn't say here, which it says, of course, in the Satipatthana discourse, the discourse on how to establish awareness, he says, and then you train, you train that you get to such a point where the sati and the panya, the awareness and the intuitive intelligence are at such a pitch that insight arises.
For some reason, that's not included here.
Okay, so that's the breath.
And then there's always this little verse at the end of things.
For one who is living heedful, he's translated as heedful here, this is apamado, one of his last two words, we normally translate it as diligent.
Atapino, which means atapi, which means that's very devoted effort.
And pihatisa, which is resolute, right?
So these are the three qualities that he expects us to have, to be diligent with the noting, with the feeling, with the seeing, to put real ardent energy into it.
Remember, this is not the energy of trying to gain something.
It's just the energy of trying to be aware of what it is, right?
So it's just enough energy, remember, just to keep the attention steady on the object and resolute.
I think I've told one or two of you, I had a meditator who I asked him how he could stay on the breath for so long.
And he says, well, I do what they do when they're pumping iron.
So rising, falling, just one more.
Rising, falling, just one more.
And that way he keeps himself resolute on observing the breath.
And then he says with whatever rushing thoughts that are dependent on the household life.
This is normally translated as regrets and planning and all that sort of stuff.
But I think I agree with him that the translates it as memories and intentions and other things like that, even Bikubodi.
But it depends how you look at the word.
And it seems to me that it makes much more sense to call them rushing thoughts, which is what we experience, isn't it?
So then thoughts constantly coming.
So it's putting those.
And when it says dependent on the household life, it means dependent on the sense pleasures.
That's what it means by the household life.
So it doesn't mean to say that a householder, or in our terms, a lay person, can't also have spiritual aims.
It's just that when you see in the scriptures this household life, he's referring to those who are entirely devoted to sense pleasures.
Okay.
and are given up when they're given up.
And with the giving up of these, the mind becomes internally stable, settles down, becomes well-pointed and concentrated.
And like this does a monk develop mindfulness related to the body.
okay when when you're reading the scriptures monk the the commentary always says it's whoever's meditating all right it's just a i can't remember what the what's the the term for that you know all hands on deck there's a term for parts to mean the whole no nobody can remember it good i'm not alone so then you've got postures so then he goes on to postures
So you've got your four postures.
And again, he says, the monk while going knows I am going.
going and coming so there's your walking meditation he knows when he's standing and when he's sitting he knows when he's lying down and whatever way his body is disposed he knows it just that way so again it's just this business of being with what you're doing yeah being you're doing actually and then there's the verse again which we've just read
And then there's the full awareness.
He translates full awareness as sampajana kari.
So kari means doing.
Pajana means to really sort of experience it.
And sam means with.
So basically, it's doing something really mindfully.
doing really mindfully what we're doing, yeah?
Sampajanukari.
And so here he's got a whole things, of course it's related to the monastic, but it's easy to translate it to ordinary daily life.
So when looking ahead or looking around, he is one who practices full awareness, right?
So now in the dining hall, I often see people picking up their plate mindfully, looking around and then keeping their eye on the food in the distance.
while their legs slowly take them to the counter and of course you have to when you get there you have to you have to watch yourself you see when you see what he when they take one you're gonna watch these thoughts let them go you know
So when he's looking around, right, okay.
So when he's bending and stretching, he practices full awareness.
When he's bearing his robe, a bowl and robes.
So, you know, when we're clothing, et cetera, he practices full awareness of what he's actually doing.
Eating, drinking, chewing and tasting.
See, it's there, the accent on the whole process of eating.
And then passing a stool in your eye, which is nicely put, it practices full awareness.
Now, often, you know, generally speaking, when it comes to that sort of activity in the laboratory, you know, we try to keep the mind somewhere else, you know, Timbuktu or something.
But it's a good practice to actually be with the whole process of evacuation.
There's a nice word.
We'll keep it Latin.
Evacuation, although I do like Anglo-Saxon words for it.
I suppose just as a little aside, you do know where the word crap comes from.
Do you know where that is?
Well, the 19th century was full of wonderful inventions.
And there was an invention of the U-pipe.
which filled up with water and stopped the smell of the sewer coming up into the room.
And the person who did that was called Mr. Crapper.
And he's not only left us with this lovely invention, but with a noun, a verb, an adverb, and an adjective.
So he's left us quite a legacy.
Poor old Mr. Crapper.
Anyway, that's by the by.
So this urine business, for a very long time, maybe, I don't know, probably about five years actually, because I started in that.
Every morning, diligently, I drank a third of my urine, according to the yoga practice.
You let a third go, you keep the middle third, and you let the rest go, and then you drink it.
and the great teaching is it's okay it's not it's actually fine and it has vitamins it has um antibiotics you've got all sorts of things in that you see and i never felt better uh unfortunately there was uh there was this other monk uh he was american and um
You can read this book called The Waters of Life, and it's all about maintaining your urine.
And he was drinking all of it, all day.
And he was coming out with great big boo-boos out of his skin.
And we said to him, you know, I mean, your skin is the biggest excretory organ we've got, actually, through the skin.
It's all coming out through the skin, you see.
And he said, no, he says, no.
He says, I've read this book.
I don't know what happened to him.
He probably disappeared on a great big sore.
Poor man.
Well, let's hope somebody told him.
Anyway, that's something that you might consider doing yourselves, right?
So the early morning pee, give a quarter away, keep a third away, a third you keep in a glass and then you, and the third, the last third you throw away and see if you can get over your disgust, right?
We'll come to that in a minute, of course.
So again, it says when standing, sitting, in sleeping, in walking, in talking and in maintaining silence.
In sleeping is a bit difficult.
I think you can either understand that to be from the moment you lie in bed until you fall asleep.
But some of you may find that as your concentration grows, you actually wake up in sleep and you know you're asleep and you're just awake in it.
And I often talk about this student I had, I haven't seen her for a very long time now, but she did lots of practice on visualizing Chinese deities or Buddhas, I can't remember.
But such was her concentration.
She told me she went to bed and she'd wake up in sleep and she'd be awake all night.
But the body would be completely asleep, the brain would be asleep, everything's asleep.
Woke up perfectly refreshed.
So that tells you something.
So that's not an aim.
That's not an aim in order to become fully liberated.
I'm just saying that's a consequence.
And in maintaining silence.
So he practices full awareness.
Full awareness.
It's just a way of reinforcing the idea that you're actually attending to what you're doing.
Yeah.
Let's have a look now.
Now the next one is, actually I should have talked about my healthy drink in this particular session because this is about the repulsiveness of the body.
So I'll just give you the background story of this.
It seems as though he gave a very detailed talk about this.
So he talked to the bhikkhus in many ways on the subject of impurity.
He spoke in praise of what is impure.
He spoke in praise of the contemplation of what is impure.
And he spoke again and again in praise of the stage of meditation on what is impure.
Because you can get to access genre, I think, with this.
And they dwelt upon the practice of contemplating what is impure in different ways.
They were troubled by their own bodies, ashamed of them,
loathing them and it is as if a woman or man when young or delicate and fond of dressing up having washed their hair would be troubled ashamed and full of loathing because they had the corpse of a snake or of a dog or of a man hung around their neck so these bhikkhus
being troubled by their own bodies, ashamed of them and loathing them, by themselves, deprived themselves of life and deprived each other of life.
Now, when the Buddha hears this, he states bhikkhus, this is not suitable at these bhikkhus.
It is not fit.
It is not proper.
It's not worthy of a disciple.
It is not good.
It should not be done.
So they obviously got very enthused about, he'd obviously given this great talk about the repulsiveness of the body.
And they just got into the repulsiveness of it and drove themselves to suicide.
It's a bit odd, isn't it?
So then, of course, he makes a rule.
This comes out of the Vinaya.
And it ends up with a rule which states this.
There are four Parājikas by which if you break any of these, you're actually no longer a monk or nun.
There's no ceremony for disrobing a monastic.
Basically, if a monastic grouping decide that somebody has committed this, they can ask him to leave the monastery.
But so long as he can get lay people to feed him and give him a place, there's very little to force him out.
He has to do it from his own conscience, really.
So then he made up this rule.
Should any bhikkhu purposefully deprive a human being of life or provide him with a life-taking knife or recommend advantages in death or encourage him to kill himself, who should in fact recommend advantages in death or encourage...
him to kill himself in various ways which with such thoughts in mind and such intentions in mind as good man what good is this is this miserable life to you death is better for you than life that that viku is defeated and no more in communion so he he didn't like that at all that they'd often
encouraged each other to kill each other or in fact kill themselves so this business of the repulsion of the body you have to be careful I don't want to hear somebody's committed suicide having drank their morning pee
So, you know, let's take it easier.
Anyway, he goes through and the idea is that as you go through it, you're not purposefully building up disgust.
You're actually trying to find out what is your relationship to these parts of the body.
And so as the images come to mind, so hairs on head, well, that rarely brings up any sense of disgust for people, you know, hairs on head.
It's the same with body hairs or it might do with certain body hairs, nails, teeth.
See, some people I know just looking just...
Looking at a tooth in your mind might bring up a certain, I don't know, skin, unless it's old and wrinkled and horrible.
Flesh, sinews, bones, bone marrow, kidneys.
So when you go through the list for yourself, you see, you're actually just trying to catch your relationship to it.
Heart, liver, spleen, lungs.
I mean, I don't know what my spleen looks like even.
I don't know.
intestines undigested food excrement bile now this is more like it bile phlegm pus blood sweat and fat now when you when you get in contact with your image or when you get in contact with with that even in ordinary daily lives as we were talking about going to going to the toilet uh just catch you know your relationship to because you ask yourself is it necessary
Now, disgust is a natural response of the body to something which it perceives as unhealthy.
So if you put rotting food in your mouth, you ought to feel disgusted.
But the emotion of disgust, like when we say we are morally disgusted,
You've just got to ask yourself, is that necessary?
Even though it might be a spontaneous reaction.
So it is with all these parts of the body.
We've learnt this, we've been taught that this stuff is to be disgusted.
But actually, when you question whether you should feel disgusted or not, as the disgust disappears, well, it's just parts of the body.
And of course, people who work with, you know, in...
Surgery and nurses and mortuaries, you know, you get over that.
In the East, if you are a monastic or you go with a monastic, if you're a layperson, you can get easy entrance into the mortuary.
and to see bodies being cut open and have a look at.
For somebody going into such a place for the first time and there's just a dead body on this table,
And the doctor, in this case, it was a woman, and she was cutting it.
There's something, the thing that strikes you about a dead body is that it is actually dead.
It's completely lifeless.
It really is quite something to stay with.
In fact, my companion who'd come with me, this other monk, he had to leave.
I think mainly because of the smell of substances that they use, you know, to keep it antiseptic and stuff, you know.
And then when the body's cut and they're investigating as to what actually caused the death, you see it's all bits and pieces.
It's quite remarkable, really, how it all fits together.
And then you see, you're supposed to say, well, you know, like this body is, so is mine, you see.
So it really is, if you're going to do this exercise, and these exercises are best done just as a little bit every day, just as a little reminder.
You don't have to go through this whole list, but just a little bit every day before your morning meditation or afterwards.
And you just run through the body and just remind yourself that this is the body.
This is how it is.
And the disgust is not necessary.
The one thing the list misses out, but was added later, was the brain, the matalunga.
And I've asked a few people about that.
nobody knows why why it was left out in the first place it became the 32nd i think isn't it 31 um i i don't i can only think that they didn't know what it was um and just to go back to what we were saying before about the senses about the um the five senses and the and the basis of the senses and um
And happily, both in the discourses and in the later work of the Abhidhamma, the mind itself, the mind door, Manodvara, is not given a sense base.
It's not actually given a sense base.
But the commentaries then began to think about this and thought, well, it should have one.
So they decided that there was a phial of blood.
Did I mention this?
Yes.
a phial of blood in the heart, in the heart, which was the base for the mental, as a mental door, the hadaya watu, the base of the heart.
And they put it, they put it actually in the heart.
And I've often wondered whether, in fact, it was sort of misplaced, that what they were connecting was this chakra, the heart chakra, which is in the middle of your chest here, and which, as you might say, is the exchange box for your emotions.
You might feel, shall we say, a certain tension in your abdomen, which you intuit is anxiety or something.
But it's only when it rises into consciousness, you feel it in the chest, don't you?
You don't feel anxious so much in your abdomen.
It comes here and it becomes anxious.
an emotion that you can recognize anger fear it's all at this at this level you see and i'm wondering whether they they mistook or they they were thinking about it because at the same time of course yoga was being developed you know anyway this file of blood um there was um one one teacher um was that was asked well if you have a heart transplant
And the blood goes into the machine.
Your heart's dead.
I mean, it's stopped.
And so the blood's being pumped by a machine.
Where's this file of blood?
We say it was in the machine.
so any excuse you know but i was very relieved to read that in fact the buddha doesn't say this either in the discourses and the people who put the abhidhamma together don't say it either and i think the reason is that the base of the of the of the mind is the whole body is the whole body the mind so any any information that comes in from the five senses
It's this secondary door, which must be all over the body as it were, sensitive to any of the five sense bases.
So that's the only way I can personally understand it.
So yes, those are the impurities.
In the monastic life where, of course, you take a vow of celibacy, this can be quite helpful because when a beautiful image comes to you, which is erotic, you then actually just image it doing something which is not very pleasant.
And immediately that desire does fade away.
Now, you don't have to be what you don't want to do is make the mistake of, you know, growing in disgust, you know, completely.
So that as soon as a beautiful image arises, you get disgust, but they should cancel each other out.
And then you're left with a state of equanimity.
But if you keep on this business of disgust, then you end up with, instead of having erotic desires, you just have a load of disgusting desires.
So it's not, you see what I mean?
It's a sort of balance really.
So that's a skillful way of using the asuba, the unlovely parts of the body.
Now that, then I think we've done this.
It then goes into the elements.
So we went through all the elements and how you can visualize them inside yourself and stuff like that.
The four elements.
I think there was also the fifth, wasn't there?
The space element.
Did we do that?
Maybe another time.
So there's the four, the fire, earth, water and air.
which symbolise the density, weight and all that, heat, elasticity, cohesiveness.
You can sometimes feel that in the breath, can't you?
Sort of a stretching of things.
And movement, movement, of course.
And there's also space, emptiness.
So it'd be like in the mouth or in the stomach or whatever, or in the ear.
The body is also full of spaces.
Anyway, we can leave that because I think I covered it in the last one.
Then we finally come to the, on the body side, the charnel grounds.
So remember in those days, the bodies were just laid out and the animals ate them.
They were wrapped in white cloth and just left out there.
And it was the white cloth that the mendicants, not just the ones of the Buddha, would take to make robes out of.
And one day when he saw a group of his monks with these ragged robes just joined together as they come, bits and pieces, he thought that didn't look so nice.
So he asked them to cut the pieces of cloth in a way that when the cloth was laid out, it looked like a paddy field.
So if you ever see amongst robes, it's got squares with sort of passageways around it.
And then to boil them with the arakanut, which gives it a sort of light brown, a light brown sort of colour.
And on top of that, he asked them to shave their heads.
And with this, they became quite distinguished from the long haired, the long hairs and the other robes.
Because the Jains, of course, dress in white.
If you see a Jane monk, they're dressed in white.
Okay, so he goes through this.
We don't have to hang around here too much.
It's just that he goes through the various stages through which a body is, you know, completely decomposes, dead after one or two days.
And then there's the next one.
After being eaten by vultures, eaten by hawks, eaten by crows.
It's all in bits and pieces.
And then the next one is held together by just a skeleton with flesh and blood bound together by tendons.
And the next one is a skeleton without flesh smeared with blood bound together by tendons.
And the next one is a skeleton no longer having flesh or blood bound together with tendons.
The tendons and the bones are the last to go.
And then it's scattered in all directions.
A bone, a hand bone here, a foot bone there, a knee bone there.
They're no longer connected as in the great song.
And then the white bones, they've been bleached by the sun like a conch shell.
And then I think there's one more, is that?
I think so, the eighth, maybe some more.
And then just a heap of bones, a year old.
So they're still hanging about, aren't they?
And then they become like powder.
Rotten bones have become like powder.
And those are your sets.
And of course, let me go back a bit, just a minute.
What have I done?
Go back one, yeah.
And with all of them, with all of those processes, the meditator says, compares it to their own very body, thinking this body is also of such a nature, such a constitution,
has not gone beyond this.
So remember our evening contemplations?
So that's the idea, that you always connect, that you always connect with the rotting body.
That's very difficult to us.
We could do it with pictures, but unfortunately these days they just burn you up and give you a casket.
I was very fortunate when my first teacher died.
She was cremated.
and um it was led by this uh nun from throttle ho she was a zen buddhist monk a zen buddhist and uh we had the um permission to go down when you know in the law of the coffins well there's there's a there's a man there who sort of gets all of the coffin he's got two ovens and um he opens the one oven which is empty takes half an hour
And he shovels this coffin in, you see.
But unfortunately, you never get to see the body burning.
So you have to go to India for that, the burning ghats.
And that's always something to watch.
If you're saying to yourself, just as this body is, mine will also be.
That's if you intend to be cremated.
So the idea is there, of course, is to really begin to sense the connection we have with the body, which goes deeper, goes real deep.
I am the body.
Just on that point, I've got time.
Okay, there's a whole chapter here in the Visuddhimagga on how to contemplate death.
and the body.
So he starts off by saying that there are types of death, there's timely death
And the development can be very simple.
You can just sit very quietly and just keep repeating to yourself.
Death will take place.
The life faculty will be interrupted.
Or you can just keep saying the word death because the word itself will lead you into your feeling about death.
Right.
Maybe come up with images.
My fear comes up, et cetera, et cetera.
But there are also contemplations, eight ways, he says, in which we can recollect death.
death, the death of our bodies.
The first one is the appearance of a murderer.
So just as a murderer appears with a sword, I shall cut this man's head off.
So that's the same as soon as you're born.
At some point, it'll be cut off.
So death is lurking behind us.
You know, that medieval tale.
I was trying to find it, but I couldn't.
Where somebody meets death and then he
He runs from it, from death, and he says, you know, well, I won't meet you.
And he runs off to the market.
And when he gets there, death's waiting for him.
So you can't escape it.
The next one is...
As a ruin of success.
So this is the old thing about whatever you've achieved, you've just got to leave behind.
All your money, all your great attainments, all your gold medals, they've all got to be left behind.
I remember that old, I remember somebody saying, somebody asked a solicitor, what did the very rich elderly lady leave behind?
And he said, everything.
And then there's the one about all health ends in sickness.
That's a contemplation.
All about sickness.
Then there's the comparison of comparing oneself to others.
So all these people who died, you know, David Bowie, that's a shock, isn't it?
You've got all these people who were perhaps icons in our lives, people we know, etc.
And they're all dead.
Recently, you probably won't know this, but there was a very good player
uh was was taking the plane across the channel and um unfortunately the plane dropped in the walk i can't remember his name uh he drowned he's only about 26 or so a great tragedy and then there's uh sharing the body with many i thought this was rather good because um they must have they must have known this is the body is shared by many
Shed by the 80 families of worms.
Creatures live in dependence on the outer skin.
Feeding on the outer skin.
Creatures live in dependence on the inner skin.
Feeding on the inner skin.
Dependence on flesh.
Feeding on the flesh.
It goes right the way through all these people.
Born, grown, die, evacuate and make water.
And even these little creatures that we know live in our bowels, for instance, help us to digest things.
Also are born, grow old, die, evacuate and make water.
So there's also this contemplation of the fact that our body is home to a lot of other little creatures, not ours, is it?
Then there's the signless death, you know, like Jesus said, you know, we know not the hour.
nor the day.
We just don't know our destiny.
We just don't know.
That contemplating.
And then the limitless of the extent, the extent of human life is short.
One who lives long lives, a hundred lives, more or less, that's all.
The life of a human kind is short.
A wise man holds it in contempt and acts as one whose head is burning.
Death will never fail to come.
A bit gloomy though, isn't it?
And then to contemplate the shortness of the moment.
So this is bringing that momentariness to our minds that in fact I'm one breath away.
I'm one half breath away from death.
I breathe in and that's the end of it.
I always like to tell this rather sad tale.
Unfortunately, I can't help but think of it as humorous.
But for the people involved, it was obviously very tragic.
But there was a woman I knew who came back who met an old love from her early life.
And they fell in love.
They were quite elderly.
And they determined to marry and live together.
And they moved into a beautiful cottage.
And one morning, he was just about on the way to get the toast and had a heart attack and died.
And I always think, if I had a piece of toasted marmalade on it,
and I was holding it here in front of my very nose and I was like that is suffering is it not so again just ending bringing the talk to an end there this contemplation of death is very powerful the Buddha says of all the contemplations this is the most powerful contemplation on death so
just a lot of stuff really to recall when you call the body, just contemplating that we don't actually experience the body, we don't experience these cells, we don't experience what the liver is doing now.
I think you might have to have some sort of extraordinary ability to be able to know that.
That when we're actually looking at the body, it's all our contemplation, a lot of our contemplation is in the body.
It's the breathing, the posture, the full awareness of what we're doing all the time.
And then there's that whole business of a relationship to the body.
So we've talked about repulsiveness, but as you know, I suggest that in the morning with the very first beverage that you have, you take the opportunity to thank the body.
And that sort of thankfulness, you know, it forms a relationship to the body.
See how wonderful it is, you know, and it makes you want to care for it, not put it in danger, not put it where it's going to fall ill, where you're going to fall over and all that sort of stuff.
A sense of gratitude.
And of course, the idea of the posture of full awareness and then the repulsiveness to use that in order to find this equanimity with the body, equanimity.
And then finally, this very strong, powerful contemplation of death.
It really is if you just bring it up.
And as I say, these exercises, like Metta, are done best every day, just for a little while, just as little reminders.
And then it sort of gets through to you.
It begins to change your attitude.
It begins to actually have an effect on you.
It's no good doing it once every year, you see.
It's the constant effort to do it.
Just a little reminder, that's all.
It does change you.
Just the matter changes you over a period of time.
It has to.
Because every time you reflect on something, you're developing a certain attitude.
And old attitudes that you have, which may be contrary to this, are not being developed.
So they atrophy.
If you don't use your muscles, they just die away.
So it's the same with these attitudes that we have, which you see as unwholesome.
If you just let them come up, feel the desire to act that way and let it go, they're slowly dying.
They're burning out.
But you have to replace it with something positive.
I can only hope my words have been of some assistance, that they have not caused even greater confusion.
May you, by your contemplation of the body, arrive at that place of perfect peace and happiness sooner rather than later.